[Musica]
che giornata
mi piace il tè da allora il piazzette
bene anche a me piace tantissimo per
spiegarvi che emozione sto vivendo in
questo momento
dovete capire che nel 2005 quando ho
scoperto i test su internet sono andato
fuori di testa e non ci sono pochi che
non ho visto dal 2005 fino ad oggi per
cui sono tantissime ore alcune sprecate
altre veramente guadagnate con tante
storie io quindi io prima ho imparato
cosa fosse un tetto poi sono arrivato in
italia nel 2007 ho imparato l'italiano
quindi oggi sono quasi pronto per fare
un tetto in italiano per riflettere su
qualcosa di molto importante che sta
molto a cuore
assieme a voi ed è proprio del mio
arrivo in italia che che vorrei partire
immaginatevi questa scena io e il mio
nuovo coinquilino ne apriamo i nostri
bagagli e cominciamo a sistemarci la
nostra nuova stanza doppia qui proprio
in centro a udine
io vengo dal israele lui viene dalla
palestina nei prossimi tre anni
abiteremo assieme ad altri ragazzi
provenienti da paesi in conflitto tra di
loro vi terremo questo appartamento
imparando tantissime cose uno sull'altro
e tantissime altre cose su noi stessi
lui tira fuori qualche fotografia che
appoggia sul comodino e poi tira fuori
la bandiera nazionale della palestina si
rivolge a me mi chiede
scusa dove la tua bandiera non la vedo
sul muro e non voglio mettere la mia se
tu non metti la tua io imbarazzata gli
rispondo non ho portato la mia bandiera
non mi piacciono molto queste cose in
realtà però mi sembra il caso quindi
vedo di risolvere e così ho fatto questo
effettivamente la nostra stanza dove
abbiamo vissuto assieme
e questo è solo l'inizio e allora non
posso finirla qui no vedete sembra
sempre più difficile vivere su questa
terra
questo era dieci anni fa quasi e sembra
sempre più difficile sembra essere tutto
in crisi crisi politica crisi economica
crisi valoriali crisi ambientale crisi
tra amanti la crisi dei migranti a volte
non serve nemmeno specificare basta dire
la crisi come se fosse una spiegazione a
tutto bene in questa confusione soltanto
una cosa mi è chiara se vogliamo vivere
meglio se vogliamo uscirne assieme da
questa confusione
allora dobbiamo imparare la convivenza
dobbiamo imparare il vivere assieme
sembra tutto rotto no ecco stasera
invece io voglio parlarvi della lezione
che io ho imparato sulla convivenza iva
di di sentire un po perché
cosa succederà se invece di avere paura
se invece di rompere tutto se invece di
vivere questi cambiamenti epocali con
preoccupazione ed è la stessa
preoccupazione da entrambe le parti
chi arriva da lontano e viene in italia
ha paura di essere escluso
e chi vive in italia vedi di arrivi ha
paura di essere escluso
questa è la tragedia e le nostre future
società saranno sempre più
multiculturali sempre più multireligiose
sempre più multietniche e se noi non ci
prepariamo a questa realtà le
conseguenze saranno disastrose si
romperà veramente tutto però cosa
succederà se invece se invece saremo
abbastanza intelligenti da preparare
noi stessi in primis poi i nostri figli
della nostra società questo nuovo futuro
in cui l'umanità continua a dialogare
continua a creare nuove identità a
devolvere a sognare assieme come abbiamo
sentito anche prima che futuro possiamo
immaginarci perché il progresso non
torna indietro allora ci adeguiamo a
questo ecco allora per farvi capire cosa
significa noi abbiamo vissuto in sette
in quell'appartamento però abbiamo
sempre raccontato che con noi abitava un
altro una specie di di piccolo mostro un
mostriciattolo che noi abbiamo chiamato
affettuosamente fraintendimento perché i
fraintendimenti tra noi erano pane
quotidiano e potevano essere
fraintendimenti piccoli come tutte
quelle tazze di tè che io ho preparato
in troppo perché non ho capito che per i
turchi questo movimento della testa
significa no ci sono voluti io direi due
litri e mezzo di te per capire che c'è
qualcosa che non va per cui gli ho
chiesto scusa non hai voluto il ten
non l'ho fatto così appunto hai fatto si
no quindi potevano essere questo tipo di
fraintendimenti però potevano anche
essere fraintendimenti più profondi come
una volta che mi ricordo chiaramente
dopo un incontro che abbiamo ottenuto in
una scuola che a mio avviso sia andata
ci è andato particolarmente bene il mio
amico palestinese sembra pensieroso un
po cupo glieli chiedo cerco di indagare
in questo successo solo per scoprire che
non è pensieroso e arrabbiatissimo ed
arrabbiato con meglio cosa ho fatto
mi chiedo è lui ma non ti rendi conto
con un altro a 100 ma è un'altra
un altro discorso non ti rendi conto
mango se fosse la mia ragazza e
e caduto l'orologio per segnare i
problemi del tempo e lui io continuo ad
indagare cosa è successo in
quell'incontro che non ho capito sia
andata così bene invece così non era per
lui
scopro che ad un certo punto
dell'incontro io ho incrociato le gambe
volgendo a lui la mia scarpa quel giorno
scoperto che nel mondo arabo questo è
considerato un insulto diretto e che ai
politici più disprezzati non si lanciano
le uova nei pomodori ma le scarpe per
cui quel giorno ho pensato che ho ancora
tanta strada da fare però col tempo e di
tempo parliamo oggi contempo abbiamo
parlato abbiamo imparato scusate a
conoscerci
abbiamo imparato molto sulle nostre
identità l'identità sono cose importanti
tante volte quando parliamo di identità
ci sembra di poter di parlare di una
cosa chiara una cosa unica
una cosa rigida un po come la carta
d'identità no ma non è così
l'identità ci aiutano a definire le
persone per cui questo è un italiano
questa un'extracomunitaria questo è un
musulmano quell'altra un ebreo a via
dicendo
di conseguenza poi appiccichiamo a
queste persone anche altre etichette per
cui italiani mafiosi ebrei i ricchi
furlans sempre amore non può altri spero
perché poi uscite 4 perché sono riforme
bene questo è pericoloso ed è pericoloso
perché se considero di te soltanto una
dimensione facile che andiamo in
conflitto se io credo in dio e tu no
non andremo mai d'accordo su nulla vero
no che non è vero
sappiamo che non è così perché lei è più
padre è un po più figlio lei è più
religioso o più italiano più donna o più
credente ma solo non sono cose che si
escludono le nostre identità sono non
sono mai piatte sono pluridimensionali a
volte sono conflittuali dentro noi
stessi ma sono sempre sempre
coloratissime e quindi così
se impara a conoscere se dedico del
tempo per conoscere il mio amico
palestinesi scopro di lui che è credente
musulmano ma un po modo suo
scopro che è patriottico ma estremamente
critico del proprio governo
scopro che vive vive di zuccheri ne
mangia una quantità veramente
imbarazzante ma che il piccante lo
tollero meglio io per cui più dimensioni
di lui imparò a conoscere e più cose
trovo che abbiamo in comune queste
dimensioni che abbiamo in comune si
intrecciano e tessono assieme una specie
di rette di sicurezza per il nostro
rapporto
le spiego perché se litighiamo la
prossima volta su uno degli aspetti
sulla fede piuttosto che la politica
piuttosto che del piccante o dello
zucchero
litighiamo di quella dimensione lì ma io
e lui conosciamo talmente tante altre
cose
uno dell'altro per cui anche se
spezziamo uno di questi fili della rette
il tessuto resta integro e noi riusciamo
a stare assieme lo stesso questa è la
stessa cosa che capita nelle famiglie
capita tra gli amici one che non si
litiga si litiga ma ci sono tante altre
cose che ci legano bisogna avere del
tempo per conoscerci per questo
penso mi direte però come l'applauso di
prima a voi quindi era un progetto
particolare eravate predisposti scelti
magari tra tante persone in palestina e
in israele e quelli bravi bravi per cui
siete persone speciali voi un pò come
gandhi persone non violente come se
fosse un gene
bene allora vi chiedo stasera che cos'è
la non violenza
ovvero come si fa la nonviolenza e non è
una domanda filosofica attenzione se io
voglio essere una persona pacifica una
persona non violenta
devo capire come comportarmi male parole
quando mi aiutano le parole mi dico non
soltanto cosa non fare non violenza o
non mi propongono un impegno positivo
per cui per tanti anni e mi sono
interrogato sulla violenza stessa e ho
cercato una definizione chiara e tonda
per la violenza perché se io riesco a
definire la violenza magari trovo una
buona definizione del suo posto nel
contrario per cui riesco ad impegnarmi
in quella direzione
non era facile ci sono voluti un po di
anni ma oggi
vi dimostro la mia definizione che
traggo dal dall'ebraico chiaro no sopra
c'è la parola violenza in ebraico ali
mood sotto c'è un'altra parola in
ebraico che contiene la stessa radice
etimologica nella seconda parola e il
mood che non può parlare che legame ci
sarebbe
io ne deduco che
la violenza è l'atto di rendere muto
qualcuno attenzione questo è vero
livello verbale a livello fisico livello
ideologico
tutto quello che vuole e non solo
significa anche che non devo usare
necessariamente la forza per essere
violento no basta non dare ascolto alla
persona
basta ignorare quello che dice per resto
quanto ci fasti disce quando una persona
fa finta di parlare con noi mentre
guarda il proprio cellulare
non è che gli chiediamo subito mi
ascolti ecco se la violenza è l'atto di
rendere muto qualcuno il suo posto e
l'ascolto e non soltanto l'ascolto in
cui io preparo la mia risposta nel
mentre che ti ascolto perché io so già
cosa tu vuoi dirmi e so già quale sarà
la mia risposta
questo non è l'ascolto ho sentito una
definizione che dice che un biologo sono
due monologhi assieme ma non stiamo
parlando veramente l'ascolto è questo
l'ascolto è presumere che io non ho
capito non ho capito perché ho fatto
delle tasse inten troppo e ho dovuto
impararlo non ho capito perché ho offeso
non ho capito nemmeno che ho offeso e
poi come ho offeso il mio amico
palestinese durante l'incontro è così
non capiamo un sacco di cose di chi è
diverso da noi e quindi è soltanto
quando dedichiamo del tempo
consapevolmente per ascoltare le persone
specie se sono diverse da noi soltanto
quando soltanto quando ci rendiamo conto
che non abbiamo capito ancora che
riusciamo a capire meglio che riusciamo
a conoscerci e questa è la mia
definizione della nonviolenza per cui
in questi tempi ed i tempi parliamo
stasera in questi tempi così tumultuosi
così difficili
vengono fuori tutte le nostre fragilità
e noi cerchiamo la stabilità vengono
fuori tutte queste crisi e noi cerchiamo
le opportunità ci sono persone forze
anche forze politiche che cercano di
dividerci e noi cerchiamo nuove reti
nuove unioni nuove fraternità
ebbene se ci ricordiamo in questi tempi
che questa terra è la casa di tutti
quanti noi e dobbiamo imparare a
conviverci dobbiamo imparare la
convivenza e se stasera mi chiedete se
questa convivenza è possibile ora posso
raccontarvi la mia esperienza e dire che
possiamo assolutamente rendere questa
terra una casa accogliente per tutti
quanti noi
se ti chiamo del tempo per ascoltare una
persona alla volta grazie del vostro
ascolto
[Applauso]